I'm so grateful for my dad first and
foremost
[Music]
if he didn't
he didn't make me more word as Bond I
would be the bad guy that people think I
am when they don't fully know me you
know when people judge me on a piece of
content I understand because I know 13
year old me and 13 year old me was
willing to do anything for the dollar
and my dad
though is so in the opposite direction
of me in so many places and I've learned
to be Who I Am by not being him it's
hard for me to talk about that about him
because I know the thing he did give me
was the biggest one that makes me me
I wouldn't be able to land it if I
didn't have that honor that he instilled
in me if he didn't eliminate that lying
for me that was there so I'm so grateful